[Music]
a Fanfare for friendship Brazilian
president Luis cenacio Lula de Silva is
the latest in a recent line of
international leaders to be given the
red carpet treatment by China's leader
Xi Jinping
in exchange a show of solidarity from
Lula towards beijing's effort to broker
a peace deal in Ukraine
Chinese State media say the leaders
agreed dialogue and negotiations are the
only way out of the conflict analysts
say that bolsters China's efforts to
work with Partners In The brics Alliance
of Brazil India Russia and South Africa
and counter a us-led strategy of
sanctioning Moscow while offering
Military Support to Ukraine it's
important to remember that Brazil is an
instrumental part of brics and more
generally speaking China's multi-polar
World Order that's touted as you know at
very least president xi's conception of
a world where you do not have a single
hegemon but instead a polycentric world
where Brazil China and other leading
countries in the global South can
comprise a prominent Paul that balances
against what they view to be Western
hegemony so to speak it's not just
Politics on the presidential agenda the
two leaders have signed a raft of
business deals covering agriculture
energy and infrastructure
foreign has been Brazil's largest
trading partner for more than a decade
last year bilateral trade topped 150
billion dollars that's almost double the
figure between Brazil and the United
States
in addition to securing new trade ties
during his time in China president Lula
has ushered in the appointment of
Brazil's former leader Dilma Rousseff as
the head of the brics new development
Bank Bangladesh Egypt Uruguay and the
United Arab Emirates are also joining
the bank it's a move that's set to
expand funding for developing countries
and extend beijing's Global sphere of
influence that's what Brazil is bringing
is bringing here I am I'm a big country
and this is not only about China this is
about the global South as we understand
it we Brazilians in China China will
accommodate that message now because
it's it's in its interest but I think we
need to realize that that that's a it's
a very very
um
asymmetric uh bricks no matter the word
Alliance it's an alliance that's
attracting increasing attention more
than a dozen countries have expressed
interest in joining bricks including
Iran and Saudi Arabia
foreign
is backing an expansion of the block if
it gets its way there may be a need for
even more red carpet rollouts in Beijing
in the near future
Kimber Al Jazeera Hong Kong